hey everyone this is feed a master Costa
Kavinsky
here for chest comm and today I'm going
to be talking about a very specific
problem that I often see in games
between players of like beginner to any
intermediate level and the problem I'm
talking about is not knowing how to
finish an attack so I want everyone to
take a look at the current position on
the board and try to figure out what you
would do here if you are playing white
obviously the black King here is very
exposed and without protection and
already white is attacking with two
pieces the Queen and the knight if you
want to you can pause the video and try
to figure out how to checkmate the
opponent as soon as possible okay
assuming you've thought about it and
pause the video thought about it more I
feel like a lot of you would start with
this move here queen h7 check so black
has to go to f8 and now what is y do
well if you give this check here the
black King is going to be out in the
open and you can continue checking him
and at some point or another your attack
will probably break through and you will
be able to deliver checkmate but this is
definitely not the best way to do it in
that position what a lot of players miss
when they're attacking is that not every
move has to be a check sometimes it's a
lot more powerful to restrict the Kings
options before you go in for the final
kill let's say for example Y started
with this check bringing the Queen very
close to the king and now play this sort
of quiet move rook e1 the idea this move
is to cut the Kings escape right now the
liking cannot get away from the attack
via the e-file and that makes them a lot
more vulnerable now white is threatening
Queen AJ checkmate and black has no good
defense so the lesson here is that when
you're attacking a lot of times it's
good to try to figure out what your
opponent is going to do in terms of
defense if you can see the way he's
going to try to escape with this King
and you can stop that then even though
you're not giving a check
you're still increasing the danger of
your attack by removing any escape path
that the other player might have let's
take a look at another example in this
position white is definitely attacking
right so I want you guys to pause the
video and take a few minutes and try to
calculate and figure out the best way
for Y to finish off the attack okay so I
think a lot of you probably saw that
white can again give this check on h7
with the Queen this time supported by
the bishop biking has to go to f8 and
now we can give this check on h8 and
blacks only defense is deployed in a g8
and now we have a really good move here
we can play Bishop a3 check and this
Bishop comes to the attack with really a
devastating effect black has to play
like rookie 7 and then we can win this
rook anytime we want we can also play
Bishop h7 and when the knight blacks
King has to continue running while we
win all of his pieces so that would have
been a great way to continue but that
wasn't the most efficient way to end the
game right and this is the takeaway from
today's lesson right you want to be as
efficient as possible in your attack you
don't want to let your opponent's
survive for lat
for longer than is necessary so the best
way to finish the attack here was with
another one of those quiet moves so we
start with queen h7 chat because black
was about to play g6 and black our
Bishop King f8 and now instead of being
hasty and giving this check on h8 we
should start with Bishop a3 pinning the
night and not allowing the knight to go
back to g8 and block this check so this
sort of quiet move Bishop a3 and blacks
resistance now he also doesn't have the
option of playing rookie 7 to give this
King another escape square e 8 and
blacks King is completely entombed so
why start is Queen h8 and the only way
to prolong the game here for black is to
play f5 note that if you plays f6 y
should play bishop g6 cutting off this
square for the King and setting up Queen
h8 mate so the best move here is f5 but
now I can simply take threatening Queen
g7 mate and after black recaptures y can
play bishop g6 again we make this move
first to control this escape square of 7
setting up both Queen f7 mate and Queen
h8 checkmate
black has no defense let's take a look
at our last example for today this
example is going to be slightly more
difficult than the last two so I want
you guys to pause your videos really
take your time and try your hardest and
find the best continuation for white
okay if you gave this check here on a 8
and the black King can escape to d7 so
you can win this pawn here but we're not
looking just to win a pawn or to we're
looking to checkmate
right
so what do we need to do we need to
control this d7 square so the black King
cannot escape and the best way to do
that is to play rook f7 controlling the
square threatening Queen e8 checkmate
and even Queen takes e7 checkmate
so black can block with his rook but
what does that do that also blocks his
King from escaping so why would just
play Queen a mate so black is forced to
take the rook and now the point of this
deflection of the Queen is so that white
can play Knight takes e5 now the knight
is controlling this square so now the
knight is controlling the d7 square and
black is helpless to the threat of Queen
a8 checkmate so I hope this serves as an
important lesson to you guys when you're
attacking that a lot of times the best
way to finish the attacks to make one of
these quiet moves that eliminate any
escape route that the opponent's king
might have I think this will be a really
useful tool in all of your games to
think about and I wish you the best of
luck in your future attacks thanks a lot
for listening and I'll see you around on
chess calm